are you doing your baby Groot
all right mm-hmm was it [ __ ] thank you I
am whoa no way I'm so good my babysitter
i night trained him I sleep trained him
really the baby nurse he was having
difficulty get playing with his devices
and I sleep trained up coming into this
universe it's such a specific universe
what was it like is there an initiation
do they even dare mess with you is it
they don't dare mess they don't even
think about barking here listen anytime
you come on any movie you got to make
that team you show them that they hired
the right person
no one can hey skirt it's all love and
all family man Homme Clementi f-- is a
new character she's so extraordinary in
this movie she's so peculiar and
beautiful and funny she does a great job
I didn't really haze her no no more like
you know welcome to the team more like
that kind of a leader
welcome to team members empower them to
do well you're one of the new characters
introduced in this film there's four new
characters in this film that had really
distinct personality traits I want to
ask you guys if you have any of these
traits mantas can change people's
feelings do you possess that trait yes
sir
wait did you say that about it's true to
catch me she moves people you were my
favorite in the movie thank you do you
have a favorite John juice actually my
favorite really why I think he just
stole the film to me and I called James
right after I watched and I thought he's
don't say no you did Zoey she's always
been really encouraging and supportive
of me but I think Rooker has just fallen
his performances she's just he's really
captivating can you believe how big this
franchise Scott yeah you can't believe
it yeah I can
you saw it it's gonna go bigger even
these characters people are loving
they're getting it and they're they're
enjoying the heck of it I appreciated
that there was a little Hasselhoff
happening in this film yeah
volume 5 volume 3 you can have any of
your childhood idols show up oh my god
there have already been so many I mean
both tango and cash are in this money
you know be cool to have like Kevin
Bacon and like a throwback from the
first one we have him come through the
third movie I mean I take Chuck Norris
damn really any of the Expendables you
know I think it'd be cool to have
Madonna play play a part Cyndi Lauper
possibly can you talk to James about
like the third one is I know he's he's
announced that it's happening and have
you guys talked about it we have talked
about it
yeah there's no room in his life to do
number three until May sixth and then we
expect him to get working immediately no
vacation no time off just start cracking
on Volume three because we're going to
have even higher expectations to surpass
next time
[Music]